Générique
-Bienvenue dans "Ces idées
qui gouvernent le monde".
Ukraine, Israël, les nouvelles
guerres de civilisation.
L'invasion de l'Ukraine
par la Russie a commencé
le 24 février 2022.
Elle se solde par des centaines
de milliers de morts
de part et d'autre
et si la résistance ukrainienne
a stoppé les envahisseurs,
la guerre dure encore
et place l'Europe
en difficulté stratégique.
La tentative d'invasion d'Israël
par le Hamas
le 7 octobre 2023
a provoqué le pire pogrom connu
par l'Etat hébreu depuis la Shoah.
Une guerre s'en est suivie
et se poursuit
avec ses morts
et ses destructions.
Quoi de commun
entre ces deux conflits ?
Forts éloignés géographiquement,
mais qui s'apparentent
par de nombreuses similitudes
géopolitiques, socioculturelles,
militaires, stratégiques
et qui témoignent d'un désordre
mondial sans précédent
relevant d'affrontements
de civilisation.
Pourquoi ce sont
des guerres de civilisation ?
Tout simplement,
parce qu'elles s'exercent
sur le temps long de l'histoire.
Elles mettent en jeu
des passions de foule
exacerbées
par des nationalismes ambiants,
font plus que des dégâts collatéraux
par leur possible
extension régionale,
qui en Europe,
qui au Moyen-Orient, voire
mondiale.
Mais aussi parce que les guerres
Ukraine-Russie et Israël-Gaza
s'inscrivent
en matière de soutien et de clivage
des grandes nations
dans la dualité politique
des rapports de force mondiaux
avec en ligne de mire un
affaiblissement de l'Occident
et un regroupement très hétéroclite
de régimes autoritaires
nommé Sud global.
Pour en parler,
je vous présente mes invités.
Edouard Guyot, vous êtes amiral,
ancien chef d'état-major des armées
de 2010 à 2014.
Philippe Gélie, vous êtes
journaliste, rédacteur en chef
du service étranger
au journal Le Figaro.
Galia Ackerman, vous êtes
historienne, journaliste
et essayiste. Claude Moniquet,
que nous avons en visioconférence,
vous êtes analyste géopolitique,
directeur de l'European Strategic
Intelligence and Security Center,
pardon pour l'accent. Jérôme Guedj,
vous êtes député,
parti socialiste.
Vous venez de voir
cette citation
de Volodymyr Zelenski.
L'impérialisme russe,
anciennement soviétique
et auparavant tsariste,
a toujours vocation
à des extensions territoriales.
Après avoir annexé
la Crimée en 2014, le Donbass
pour suivre et plus encore
aujourd'hui, est-ce à dire
que la Russie est mal à l'aise
dans un territoire
bordé de frontières et cherchera
toujours à s'agrandir ?
Galia Ackerman ?
-C'est un peu inscrit,
si vous voulez,
dans la matrice
de l'Empire russe,
qui avait vocation,
affichée par plusieurs tsars,
de s'agrandir.
Je crois
que c'était Catherine II qui disait
que l'Etat russe, pour se défendre,
doit nécessairement s'élargir.
Et c'est surtout le 19e siècle
qui a connu
des élargissements spectaculaires
sur l'Asie centrale,
l'Extrême-Orient,
aussi les frontières
occidentales de la Russie.
Donc il n'y a rien de nouveau là.
-Sauf
qu'en 1990-1991, il s'est rétréci.
-Voilà.
Il s'est rétréci à plusieurs
reprises, il faut le savoir,
parce que,
déjà après la révolution de 1917,
Lénine n'a pas réussi à conserver
tous les territoires de l'Empire
russe et donc il y a eu toujours
des griefs vis-à-vis
de la Pologne, des pays baltes
et de la Finlande en particulier.
Maintenant, en 91,
l'Union soviétique se décompose,
Elstine accepte l'idée
des frontières existantes
et puis,
quand Poutine arrive au pouvoir,
les idées revanchistes font
peu à peu leur chemin
et maintenant, on parle
même de façon encore
informelle
de la reconquête de l'Alaska.
-Merci.
-Sans parler
de l'Ukraine.
-Merci.
-Philippe Gélie,
est-ce le propre de l'impérialisme
que d'élargir ses frontières ?
Parce qu'aujourd'hui, on connaît des
pays qui n'ont pas de frontières,
mais il y a énormément
de contestations frontalières.
Est-ce que
tous ces pays ont
une tendance impérialiste ?
-Impérialisme et expansionnisme
vont souvent de pair en effet,
mais la question
que ça pose à mon sens,
c'est celle de ce qu'on met en face.
C'est-à-dire que la Russie
a, je pense,
comme le dit Galia,
ces espèces de gènes
un peu expansionnistes,
mais aussi cette culture
de mettre tous les Russes
sous le même chapeau, sous le même
parapluie. Partout où il y a
des Russes, c'est la Russie.
Il n'y a pas non plus
des Russes dans le monde entier.
Donc il y a un moment,
Vladimir Poutine
en campagne électorale
a déclaré et ça figure
sur des affiches à Moscou :
"Les frontières de la Russie
ne s'arrêtent nulle part."
Pour nous, ça paraît
un peu vertigineux,
mais je pense que c'est
une figure rhétorique
assez banale dans la psychologie
politique russe et toute la question
est de savoir si, en face,
il y a des Européens forts,
une OTAN forte, des Américains
présents, capables de dire
aux Russes : "Là, pour vous,
"c'est la ligne que nous traçons
et que vous ne pouvez pas dépasser."
Bien sûr, il y a le cas
de l'Ukraine où la ligne
a été dépassée.
-Oui, alors,
d'un point de vue militaire,
qu'en dites-vous, amiral ?
-C'est assez compliqué.
On a d'ailleurs des parallèles
à faire entre ce qui se passe
à Gaza d'un côté...
-On va l'aborder juste après.
-Et ce qui se passe en Ukraine.
Ce que ces deux conflits
nous montrent, et c'est là
où on en arrive ensuite
aux civilisations
qui sous-tendent les Etats,
ce que ces deux conflits
nous montrent,
c'est d'abord que la paix
n'est pas définitivement acquise.
On se souvient de l'affaire
des dividendes de la paix.
Ce que le monde occidental
avait totalement oublié.
Le réveil est assez...
...est assez brutal.
La 2e chose que ça nous montre,
c'est que la technologie
ne remplace pas tout.
L'art de la guerre n'a pas
fondamentalement changé,
les outils utilisés sont
différents.
Si la technologie remplaçait
tout, les Ukrainiens, qui ont eu
la technologie occidentale,
auraient remporté
plus de victoires. Le facteur humain
reste absolument prégnant.
Et le Hamas aurait été détecté
avant et là, on voit bien
que ça devient
une affaire de renseignements.
C'est le facteur humain.
Quelque part, c'est rassurant
de se dire que l'homme reste
au centre de la boucle,
mais là aussi, nous l'avions oublié.
Et donc, à partir de là,
oui, on peut
basculer
sur les civilisations, mais
la civilisation russe
fondamentalement est pas
si différente de la civilisation
ouest-européenne. Par contre,
très différente de la chinoise,
de l'indienne, voire
plus différente de ce qu'il y a
en Amérique du Sud.
C'est sous cet angle
qu'il faut regarder.
-Jérôme Guedj,
je voudrais vous laisser
répondre sur les frontières,
mais à travers les deux conflits.
Si on prend
le conflit israélo-palestinien,
on sait bien qu'il est parsemé
de crises et de guerres
et il y a jamais eu
d'accord territorial
malgré la décision de l'ONU en 48,
d'attribuer à la fois Israël
aux Palestiniens,
malgré les accords d'Oslo.
L'une des revendications phares
palestiniennes,
telle qu'elle s'est exprimée
après le 7 octobre,
c'était : "From the river
"to the see."
De la rivière du Jourdain
à la Méditerranée.
En somme, un Etat palestinien
qui effacerait de facto Israël.
Revendication reprise tout récemment
par Khaled Mechaal,
l'un des dirigeants
les plus importants du Hamas.
De surcroît,
cet impérialisme-là se nourrit
d'un ingrédient religieux
qui s'appelle
la Oumma ou communauté islamique.
Comment sortir
à votre avis
de cet absolutisme territorial ?
-Bah d'abord en rappelant,
c'est le point commun
aux deux conflits,
la question des frontières
dont on pouvait penser
qu'elle n'était peut-être
plus aussi centrale
dans les relations internationales,
qu'une forme de stabilisation
pouvait résulter... Ma génération
avait 20 ans à la chute
du mur de Berlin.
On nous expliquait que la fin
de la Guerre froide allait permettre
la fin de l'histoire,
la victoire
de la démocratie libérale,
du modèle de l'économie de marché,
bon. C'est tout le contraire qui
s'est passé. Et donc, on a
vu ressurgir comme jamais
la contestation des frontières
à travers le monde.
On parle de ces 2 endroits,
parce que...
En tous les cas, l'atteinte
à l'intégrité territoriale
de l'Ukraine par la Russie, eu égard
les 2 protagonistes et notamment
l'un membre du Conseil
de Sécurité de l'ONU, donc garant
de la charte de l'ONU, qui elle-même
garantit les frontières.
Là, on était dans la contradiction
absolue de ce nouvel ordre mondial,
l'expression est plus
utilisée,
on l'utilisait beaucoup avant.
Cette question des frontières
et le fait d'en invoquer du coup
le droit international
est absolument cruciale.
Dans le cas Israël-Gaza,
il faut quand même apporter
un petit... un petit bémol.
"From the river to the sea",
c'est-à-dire la destruction
de l'Etat d'Israël,
c'est la revendication
du projet théocratique
portée par le Hamas.
Le problème aujourd'hui,
c'est que le reste de l'expression
politique palestinienne
qui devrait, pourrait passer
par l'autorité palestinienne
est totalement
démonétisée, décrédibilisée,
inaudible.
La question des frontières,
pour aller droit au but, là-bas,
elle passe à un moment donné,
une fois qu'on a dit
que l'attaque terroriste du Hamas
est insupportable,
condamnable, le pogrom, vous l'avez
rappelé, mais elle remet...
elle rend inévitable la question
des frontières d'un Etat palestinien
et de la reconnaissance d'un Etat
et donc d'une solution politique.
Je vais aussi ajouter un point,
parce que c'est
une question au vu du choix
du thème de débat retenu.
Est-ce que dans les deux cas
on est vraiment
dans des guerres de civilisation ?
Je suis très méfiant, je vous
parlais du nouvel ordre mondial,
le début des années 90,
je pense à Samuel Huntington,
on nous théorisait
le choc des civilisations...
-On va en parler.
-Oui,
mais en filigrane,
il y a cette idée aussi
qui a pu être utilisée
que c'est le combat
du bien contre le mal.
Et si on est dans le combat du bien
contre le mal, on ne peut plus faire
de géopolitique et on a
un surplomb
moral terrible
qui rend inatteignable
la complexité
des relations internationales.
Je récuse un peu le terme.
-On va en parler,
parce que là, on avait
décliné un point commun,
la question des frontières.
Philippe Gélie, est-ce qu'il y a
pas un autre point commun
dans la question de la démographie ?
Parce que si on prend
les deux conflits,
on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
des déplacements de population.
Si on prend l'Ukraine,
on pense qu'il y a 10 millions
d'Ukrainiens déplacés
depuis la guerre
à cause de la guerre
et si on prend le conflit à Gaza,
vous avez la population
du nord et du sud d'Israël qui est
aujourd'hui déplacée
et les déplacements
de population à Gaza.
Donc comment vous appréhendez
cette question ?
-C'est la guerre. C'est
l'effet de la guerre.
Vous avez parlé d'impérialisme,
impérialisme russe,
vous avez laissé entendre
qu'il y avait un impérialisme
du Hamas, ça me fait penser
qu'il y a un impérialisme
du puissant et du faible.
L'impérialisme du Hamas
ne remet pas en cause,
si on peut le qualifier comme tel...
-Il se sert de la démographie ?
-Non. Les déplacements
de population sont le résultat
des bombardements massifs
sur des zones
habitées par des civils.
Dans les deux cas. Le problème
qu'on a en l'occurrence, c'est que,
et si conflit de civilisations
il y a, du moins,
si on nous le reproche,
c'est parce que dans un cas on juge
que c'est parfaitement inacceptable
que la Russie
envahisse l'Ukraine et bombarde
les populations civiles du Donbass
et dans l'autre cas, un certain
nombre de décideurs occidentaux
jugent justifié que les représailles
contre les crimes du Hamas
soient opérées
de la manière
dont elles le sont par Israël,
qui a la main, qui a la puissance,
militaire en l'occurrence.
Je ne dis pas que le Hamas
est inoffensif, loin de là,
mais la supériorité militaire
est clairement du côté d'Israël.
Ce que vous disiez
sur l'impérialisme du Hamas,
on peut le retourner
et poser la question
de l'impérialisme israélien,
puisqu'il y a aussi des extrémistes
en Israël qui disent la même chose :
"Israël, du Jourdain à la mer."
Donc là, je ne mets pas
sur un parallèle absolu
les deux situations,
mais effectivement leurs causes sont
différentes, leurs ressorts aussi.
Après, dans les manifestations
qu'entraîne la guerre,
il y a beaucoup de points communs.
-Claude Moniquet,
sur la question à la fois
des frontières, de la démographie
et du lien entre les deux conflits,
qu'en pensez-vous ?
*-Alors, sur le lien
entre les deux conflits surtout,
je pense que ce qui fait
la force de la Russie aujourd'hui,
c'est notre faiblesse.
C'est le fait
qu'après la fin de la Guerre froide,
l'Europe s'est gentiment assoupie
dans le beau, magnifique rêve du
soft power en pensant qu'on pouvait
tout régler par la diplomatie,
par le commerce international,
par le libre-échange
et par l'extension de la démocratie.
On voit bien aujourd'hui avec ce Sud
global que vous évoquiez
que le modèle démographique
ne séduit pas tout le monde,
que certains Etats non démocratiques
comme la Chine,
comme l'Inde, dont le côté
démocratique peut être discuté,
ne fonctionnent pas si mal que ça.
Et donc peuvent représenter,
peuvent attirer
une partie de l'opinion mondiale.
On a oublié qu'en définitive,
et c'est vrai malheureusement,
ces leçons d'histoire.
On est au 21e siècle,
on est dans une période
qui devrait être assagie,
l'histoire reste ce qu'elle est
et dans l'histoire,
les conflits se règlent
le plus souvent malheureusement
par la guerre et par la violence.
Nous l'avons oublié.
Nous nous sommes désarmés,
nous avons envoyé des signaux
de faiblesse. On voit très bien
aujourd'hui à la fois dans notre
réponse à ce qui passe en Ukraine
et dans les divisions qui peuvent
exister dans le soutien
que nous apportons à Israël.
-Claude Moniquet,
à votre avis, une précision,
nous allons aborder le cas de l'Iran
un peu plus avant dans l'émission,
mais ce que vous avez dit
concernant l'Occident et la Russie,
l'affaiblissement de l'Occident,
la Russie en a profité.
A votre avis, et sans développer
plus largement la question,
pensez-vous que l'Occident s'est
montré faible vis-à-vis de l'Iran
et l'Iran en a profité
avec ce conflit du 7 octobre ?
Faites-vous un parallèle
entre les deux à ce niveau-là ?
-Je pense que malheureusement,
l'Europe en tout cas
s'est montrée faible
avec l'Iran autour des questions
des négociations nucléaires.
On a bien vu et je serai très court,
et c'est prouvé
rapport de l'Agence atomique
après rapport de l'Agence atomique,
depuis des années, depuis 20 ans,
l'Iran se moque du monde,
l'Iran trompe les inspecteurs,
l'Iran dissimule un programme
qui a des finalités militaires,
et nous continuons à dire
qu'il faut retourner discuter.
Je pense effectivement que... Je dis
pas qu'il faut bombarder l'Iran,
mais cette idée
effectivement chez les Iraniens
a clairement entraîné la conclusion
que l'Europe était faible
et que la seule puissance
avec laquelle il fallait compter
était les Etats-Unis.
-Qu'en pensez-vous, amiral ?
-Je suis complètement
d'accord. Plutôt qu'une guerre
entre civilisations,
c'est une guerre faite
à ce que nous pourrions appeler
la civilisation occidentale.
Et pourquoi est-elle faite ?
Les hommes étant ce qu'ils sont,
c'est toujours la loi du plus fort
qui va vouloir prévaloir,
qui va tenter de prévaloir. Nous
nous sommes montrés globalement
et collectivement assez faibles.
Ca donne le conflit en Ukraine.
Ca donne Gaza. Et ça peut donner
d'autres points de friction
dans le monde.
-Galia Ackerman ?
-Je voudrais peut-être faire
deux remarques.
D'une part, il y a souvent confusion
entre le problème palestinien,
qui est un problème véritable
et très ancien déjà,
et le Hamas
et les revendications du Hamas
qui veut tout simplement
la destruction d'Israël.
Il faut rappeler
que l'autorité palestinienne,
au moins officiellement,
ne veut pas de destruction d'Israël
et reconnaît l'existence de l'Etat
d'Israël,
de même que plusieurs pays arabes.
Pas tous, bien sûr.
Donc, ce qui se passe
dans le cas du Hamas,
c'est qu'une organisation
terroriste, reconnue comme telle,
par les Etats-Unis et l'Europe,
s'est emparée d'un Etat
et donc l'Etat
qui était installé à Gaza,
on peut le comparer
par exemple à Daesh
ou plus anciennement à al-Qaida.
Et il a toujours été reconnu
par l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
comme légitime
l'intention de détruire
ces Etats terroristes.
Ce qui se passe actuellement,
ce n'est pas une vengeance,
ce n'est pas
une réponse tout simplement
à cette attaque purement terroriste,
le pogrom qui a eu lieu
le 7 octobre de l'année dernière,
c'est qu'Israël a compris que,
tant que le Hamas n'est pas éradiqué
dans la bande de Gaza,
il n'y a pas
de cohabitation possible.
Maintenant, on peut discuter,
est-ce que toutes les mesures
prises par Israël
sont justifiées ou non,
mais essentiellement,
c'est une guerre
contre une entité terroriste
qui prône la destruction totale
d'Israël.
-On va
contextualiser ça, Jérôme Guedj.
-Donc...
D'une part, c'est ça. Et ensuite,
c'est vrai que... voilà,
je réagis à ce qui vient
d'être dit par l'amiral,
qu'en effet, les deux conflits,
n'étant pas pour moi
conflits
entre civilisations.
-On va avancer dans ce domaine.
-OK.
-Moi, je voudrais revenir
sur cette question.
1990, 1991,
la chute du communisme,
la chute du mur de Berlin,
on a pensé, on s'est trompé,
qu'on pouvait démocratiser
la Russie.
La chute de l'Etat islamique,
on a pensé que les pays
arabo-musulmans seraient conciliés
avec la démocratie. Les conflits
sont toujours là,
que ce soit en Syrie, en Irak,
on voit l'explosion du Hamas,
etc. A votre avis,
ça prouve que l'histoire
est irrationnelle
dans le cas,
on le voit et on voit comment
on s'est trompés. Par rapport
à cette histoire irrationnelle
et qui produit des crises
un peu partout dans le monde,
le politique que vous êtes
ne se dit pas
que, finalement,
c'est une défaite politique ?
Parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
et on n'arrive pas à influer
sur la conflictualisation du monde.
-Cela renvoie
à ce que je disais tout à l'heure.
Je veux pas donner l'impression
d'avoir la nostalgie de la Guerre
froide dans laquelle
les deux figures tutélaires,
l'URSS et les Etats-Unis,
s'assuraient au moins
des souverainetés territoriales,
des intégrités, n'étaient
pas parties prenantes elles-mêmes.
Je réinsiste sur ce point.
L'implication directe
de la Russie dans le conflit
avec l'Ukraine, c'est une bascule
fondamentale.
On n'est plus dans des conflits
par alliés ou par territoires
interposés
en Afghanistan ou ailleurs.
Je veux pas avoir la nostalgie
de cette période-là, évidemment,
parce qu'il fallait sortir
de la menace
qu'elle pouvait représenter.
Mais c'est vrai qu'on a probablement
péché par angélisme
dans la chute du mur de Berlin
et d'ailleurs probablement
dans cette décennie
qui aurait dû être celle
de la construction
de ce nouvel ordre mondial,
la décennie en gros
entre 89 et 2001, à ce moment-là,
on a une autre bascule qu'est
le 11 septembre 2001 avec,
la nature ayant horreur du vide,
l'irruption cette fois-ci de celle
des revendications et c'est ça
que je trouve intéressant,
pardonnez-moi l'expression, dans ce
qui se passe entre Israël et Gaza,
là, on a une revendication
de nature identitaire religieuse,
qui s'impose et qui matrice
la totalité
des relations internationales.
En disant cela, je ne veux pas pour
autant, je redis ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure,
derrière le terme de guerre
des civilisations,
il y a toujours ce risque
d'avoir...
-N'ayez pas peur des mots.
-Non, je dis juste que
si on le fait, le risque,
c'est le conflit
entre le bien et le mal
et l'assignation
du bien à l'Occident
et du mal à ce Sud global.
C'est en filigrane ce qui peut
transpirer.
-On va en parler.
Philippe Gélie,
on a parlé de l'Iran.
L'Iran livre des drones
à la Russie.
Ces drones ont massacré
la population ukrainienne.
L'Iran arme le Hezbollah,
arme le Hamas,
arme les Houthis.
Sincèrement, à votre avis,
qu'est-ce que veut l'Iran
et qu'est-ce que peut l'Iran
dans ce conflit
et dans ces deux conflits ?
-Si on prend le cas de l'Iran,
à mon sens, il s'inscrit assez bien
dans votre thématique, parce que,
si conflit de civilisations il y a,
je pense qu'il se joue
entre l'Ouest et le reste.
Je crois plus à l'Ouest global
qu'au Sud global, qui est en fait,
beaucoup plus hétéroclite
que l'Ouest global
et dans l'Ouest global, il y a aussi
Israël et ce ne sont pas
des concepts géographiques.
Et en face de l'Ouest
global, il y a des puissances
dont la force
s'exprime essentiellement
par leur capacité de nuisance.
Je mets
dans cette catégorie la Russie,
qui est une puissance à la hauteur
de sa capacité de nuisance,
et on voit qu'elle est grande,
et l'Iran, il en va
de même. Et donc, dans leur...
A mon sens, je suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que l'Ouest global,
dont parle, paie sa naïveté
ou sa faiblesse, il paie aussi
sa domination du monde
pendant des décennies
après la Deuxième Guerre mondiale.
On a imposé un système,
un ordre international,
qui avait beaucoup de vertus,
mais dont on n'a pas
toujours respecté
nous-mêmes les règles
quand les Etats-Unis
ont envahi l'Irak
ou quand Israël ne respecte pas
les résolutions
de l'ONU
et il y en a eu des dizaines
qui lui demandaient de respecter
les territoires conquis après 67.
Et donc, aujourd'hui,
on paie d'une certaine manière
la facture. Je dis pas que c'est
bien fait pour nous, mais on est
face à ces puissances qui ont
une grande capacité de nuisance.
C'est le cas de l'Iran
qui active tous ses relais,
probablement en collusion
plus ou moins étroite
avec la Russie.
Ce qui se passe au Moyen-Orient
avantage,
enfin, convient, est
une espèce d'aubaine pour Poutine
dans sa guerre en Ukraine.
Et, alors, à une époque
George W. Bush parlait
de l'axe du mal,
Benyamin Netanyahou a repris
cette expression ces derniers temps.
On va pas rentrer
dans cette rhétorique-là,
mais on voit bien
que si affrontement
civilisationnel
entre guillemets il y a,
pour moi, il est entre ces deux
groupes de force. Pour autant,
je pense qu'une guerre
de civilisations, c'était
par exemple entre les Empires
austro-hongrois et ottomans.
Oui, on pouvait parler de guerre
de civilisations. Aujourd'hui,
c'est plutôt une guerre pour
reprendre sa place ou rééquilibrer
les équilibres mondiaux.
-Galia Ackerman, pouvez-vous dire
ce que vous pensez de ce rôle
de trait d'union de l'Iran ?
-Je pense que l'Iran a
ses propres intérêts.
Pour Israël,
il a proclamé officiellement
le désir de détruire Israël.
C'est son objectif prononcé.
Donc il est tout à fait normal
qu'il soutienne
tous les mouvements terroristes
que vous avez déjà énumérés.
Quant à la Russie,
c'est un partenariat stratégique
d'une autre nature. L'Iran n'a aucun
intérêt particulier en Ukraine.
Mais il est partenaire de la Russie
qui développe son énergie nucléaire
et ils ont beaucoup de projets
de coopération.
Il y a aussi cette idée en effet,
dont Philippe a parlé,
d'affaiblir, voire de détruire
l'Occident.
Ca, c'est une revendication
idéologique, qui n'est pas en soi
strictement civilisationnelle
pour nous, parce que,
quand on parle d'un conflit
de civilisations,
il faut que les deux parties
soient en conflit.
Nous, on n'est pas
en conflit...
-N'ayez pas peur
des mots.
-Mais la Russie, par exemple,
a ouvertement proclamé,
ça fait partie
de sa doctrine maintenant,
qu'il faut détruire l'Occident,
qu'il y a une civilisation
occidentale,
il y a une civilisation russe,
ce qui est fort à-propos,
parce que la civilisation russe
historiquement fait partie,
comme ça a été déjà signalé ici...
-On vous a entendue.
-Ce que je veux dire,
c'est qu'il y a...
Comment dirais-je ?
Le combat affiché
contre l'Occident par la Russie.
Pour l'Iran, pour des raisons
aussi idéologiques et religieuses,
il est important
de combattre également
l'influence occidentale.
-Je vous ai entendue, Galia.
Je voudrais poursuivre sur cette
question avec vous, Edouard Guyot.
L'Iran aujourd'hui a obtenu
une victoire avec le 7 octobre.
L'impossibilité d'établir
des relations entre Israël
et l'Arabie saoudite,
qui auraient concrétisé
une apothéose des accords d'Abraham
noués par Trump.
A votre avis, si Trump est réélu,
est-ce que quelque chose
peut changer dans ce domaine ?
Parce qu'on sait
quelle était sa position
vis-à-vis de l'Iran.
-Je pense qu'il va falloir que tous,
nous relisions l'un de ses livres,
qui était "L'art de la négociation",
"The Art of the Deal".
Trump est un homme d'affaires,
qui a toujours considéré
qu'il fallait négocier.
On l'a vu avec l'affaire
des accords d'Abraham.
Et donc, oui,
une élection de Trump
rebattrait les cartes.
Mais il y a une chose qui ne va pas
changer, c'est que l'Iran,
comme la Russie,
et Mme Ackerman vient de le rappeler
a des buts de guerre affichés.
Ou le Hamas,
le Hamas, c'est la destruction
d'Israël, c'est bien connu.
Quels sont les buts de guerre
du bloc occidental ?
Les militaires ont toujours besoin
de buts de guerre
pour savoir ensuite
comment passer
de la stratégie générale
à la stratégie militaire
et à la tactique.
Quels sont les buts de guerre
de l'Occident global ?
Les valeurs ? Allez expliquer ça
à quelqu'un
qui n'a pas d'eau, qui n'a pas
d'électricité ou qui a une histoire
multimillénaire, mais qui n'a rien
à voir avec celle de l'Europe.
Nous n'avons pas encore été
capables, nous, Occidentaux,
et le bloc occidental
est assez large,
j'aime bien l'idée d'Ouest global,
nous n'avons pas encore été
capables de déterminer
quels étaient nos buts de guerre,
alors que
c'est nous qui sommes agressés,
nous, globalement.
-Claude Moniquet
veut intervenir.
-Oui, sur l'Iran, mon impression,
c'est que la Russie a un intérêt
direct face à l'Europe
qui est effectivement d'écarter
l'Europe et surtout l'OTAN
de ses frontières et de construire
une espèce de glacier
à partir d'anciens pays, de
pays qui appartenaient anciennement
à l'Union soviétique
comme l'Ukraine,
peut-être demain
la Moldavie ou la Géorgie.
La stratégie de l'Iran
est différente.
La stratégie de l'Iran est dirigée
essentiellement
contre les pays sunnites du Golfe,
contre l'Arabie saoudite
et contre les autres pays sunnites
et contre Israël.
Et quand l'Iran s'attaque
à l'Occident
et l'Iran s'attaque à l'Occident,
je vous rappelle qu'en octobre 83,
les Iraniens,
par Hezbollah interposé,
ont assassiné 200 soldats américains
et 68 soldats français à Beyrouth.
Je vous rappelle les attentats
commis par l'Iran à Paris
entre 2015, pardon,
entre 1986 et 1987.
Donc, quand l'Iran nous attaque,
c'est pour nous éloigner
de la scène moyen-orientale.
L'Iran voit bien que nous sommes,
nous, l'Ouest
global dont nous parlions,
les Etats-Unis
et une partie de l'Europe,
nous sommes non seulement
les soutiens d'Israël
et des amis d'Israël ou des alliés,
mais nous sommes aussi des alliés
du monde arabe modéré,
du monde sunnite du Golfe.
Et c'est pour ça que
les Iraniens veulent nous écarter
par tous les moyens
de cette région
pour se retrouver
dans une espèce de huis clos,
où il y aurait eux,
les pays sunnites et Israël.
Leur but aussi,
par rapport aux pays sunnites,
c'est de montrer
via leur soutien au Hamas
qu'ils sont les seuls aujourd'hui
à réellement soutenir,
et je mets des guillemets,
la cause palestinienne.
C'est une stratégie à tiroirs,
assez typiquement iranienne,
mais qui peut fonctionner et qui
fonctionne. Quand on voit qu'on a,
sur la question du Hamas,
quand même l'Iran qui soutient
qui arme, qui finance,
une organisation
qui est directement issue
des Frères musulmans,
qui sont ce que le sunnisme
a de plus extrémiste,
c'est quand même assez étonnant.
-Merci. Un mot,
Jérôme ?
-Non, mais je pense
que dans les deux conflits,
puisqu'on cherche
des points de convergence,
cette question des buts de guerre
est essentielle.
Elle est clairement identifiée,
vous l'avez dit,
du côté de la Russie.
Le but de guerre, c'est
de se glisser dans ce qu'on évoquait
au début de l'entretien,
à savoir de repousser
les frontières de l'Empire
russe, a fortiori quand il a
le sentiment à tort ou à raison
qu'il est menacé.
Ce qui pose la question
de la manière dont nous concevons
le rôle aujourd'hui de l'OTAN.
Il ne faut jamais oublier,
je dis pas ça pour trouver
des circonstances
atténuantes évidemment à la Russie,
mais que la manière
dont le changement de nature de
l'OTAN, en tous les cas, à travers
l'extension jusqu'aux frontières
de la Russie de cette alliance, a
pu,
encore une fois, je le pense,
à tort, fournir... En tous les cas
a fourni le prétexte et donc
c'était une interprétation
à tort pour la Russie
pour se glisser dans ces buts-là.
Les buts du Hamas,
ils sont identifiés.
Casser le rapprochement,
ça a été rappelé,
entre Israël et le prolongement
des accords d'Abraham,
et donc probablement même
casser la possibilité
d'une solution à deux Etats
pour utiliser ce kyste palestinien,
pardon, comme un facteur
de déstabilisation globale.
Donc nos adversaires,
en tous les cas, voilà,
leurs buts sont
identifiés. En réponse,
c'est là que nous avons
une grande difficulté. Du côté
israélien, c'est le problème
de Benyamin Netanyahou aujourd'hui,
avoir deux buts de guerre
à un moment contradictoires.
Libérer tous les otages,
il ne faut pas oublier qu'ils sont
la prolongation de ce pogrom,
et, en même temps, démilitariser,
éradiquer, neutraliser le Hamas.
Les deux buts de guerre ne sont pas
atteignables, à tel point
qu'on a le sentiment avec Benyamin
Netanyahou aujourd'hui que le but
de la guerre,
la fin de la guerre si j'ose dire,
c'est presque une guerre sans fin,
une guerre
qui s'autoalimente elle-même.
-Je vous ferais simplement
remarquer, Jérôme Guedj,
que l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
considèrent que le Hamas
est un groupement
terroriste.
-Evidemment.
-Et qu'après le 7 octobre,
l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
a considéré qu'il fallait détruire
le Hamas.
-Que veut dire,
détruire le Hamas ?
Quand vous avez Gadi Eizenkot
du cabinet de guerre israélien,
qui dit :
nos buts ne sont pas identifiés,
donc on ne peut pas gagner
la guerre.
-Je vous rappelle ça.
Alors, revenons à notre débat.
Ces conflits, parmi d'autres
conflits à haute intensité,
ont des répercussions mondiales
qui ébranlent l'économie,
les sociétés, et accroissent
le désordre mondial.
Nous sommes tous d'accord.
Mais comment vous expliquez
le soutien de franges
politiques dites progressistes
et du wokisme,
une forme de convergence
d'ailleurs intersectionnelle,
entre le wokisme et une gauche
très progressiste, à un irrédentisme
islamopolitique
et symétriquement,
l'appui de très nombreuses nations
à la Russie ? Philippe Gélie.
-Vaste débat.
-Oui, parce qu'on est là
dans cet...
-Le général, mais
non, ce que je pense,
c'est qu'on est dans le piège
du deux poids deux mesures,
ce que les Anglo-Saxons appellent
le double standard.
C'est une accusation
qui nous est faite,
à laquelle on peut
très difficilement échapper.
Parce que, ceux qui vous disent :
dans un cas, vous considérez
qu'il est légitime
de mener une guerre
très brutale,
de bombardements,
y compris sur une ville
comme Gaza, la ville de Gaza, etc.,
au nom des représailles
et de l'objectif jugé légitime
d'éradiquer le Hamas.
D'un autre côté,
vous avez Poutine
qui tient un discours exactement
parallèle. Il dit,
en Ukraine, il y a un régime
nazi. Nous, on n'est pas d'accord
et on estime que c'est
de la propagande de bas étage,
mais sur la scène mondiale,
c'est perçu,
il y a une certaine équivalence
dans l'analyse qu'on peut faire
de ces deux discours.
Et donc,
il y a, dans nos sociétés,
des courants,
que vous les appeliez wokisme
ou autres, qui considèrent
que nous sommes piégés
par ce deux poids deux mesures,
que ce deux poids
deux mesures existe.
On peut vouloir y échapper,
mais c'est très difficile.
Et, d'autre part,
ce que nous défendons,
si nos arguments sont valides
pour dénoncer l'invasion brutale
et les crimes de guerre commis
par Poutine en Ukraine,
nous devrions aussi dénoncer
la politique israélienne,
militariste et belliciste
d'un gouvernement qui ne veut pas
partager.
-Vous reconnaissez
que les soutiens socioculturels sont
identifiés
d'un côté comme de l'autre.
-Oui, enfin, c'est pas...
-C'est ce que l'on observe.
-C'est pas non plus une exclusivité,
me semble-t-il.
Il y a des tas de gens
qui se posent la question
de savoir
comment soutenir validement
de manière cohérente
la résistance ukrainienne.
Quand un jeune Ukrainien
lance un cocktail Molotov
sur un char russe, c'est un héros.
Quand un jeune Palestinien
fait la même chose
sur un char israélien, c'est un
terroriste. Cette contradiction-là,
nous ne l'avons pas surmontée
globalement,
en tant que société occidentale.
-Si vous permettez,
votre cartographie ne tient pas,
car je ne crois pas
que l'extrême droite européenne
et française notamment peut être
identifiée au wokisme
dont vous parliez à l'instant.
Or les sympathies
à l'endroit du régime poutinien,
elles viennent,
en France en tous les cas,
de cette mouvance-là davantage
que du wokisme ou de la gauche.
-Elle existe aussi
à l'extrême gauche.
-Oui, mais l'extrême gauche n'est
pas la gauche dans son ensemble.
-Oui, Galia
Ackerman.
-Je pense
que Philippe Gélie a tort, parce que
on ne peut pas, absolument pas,
mettre sur le même plan
l'action militaire
qui est menée en Ukraine
et celle qui est menée
dans la bande de Gaza.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que vous faites abstraction
de qui est l'agresseur
et qui est l'agressé.
Dans le cas de la Russie,
c'est la Russie qui est agresseur.
Donc on assiste
à une légitime défense. Dans le cas
du Hamas et donc du pseudo-Etat
créé dans la bande de Gaza,
c'est le Hamas l'agresseur
et c'est l'action d'Israël
qui, en principe, est défensive,
même si on peut discuter
de tel ou tel épisode.
-Je n'ai pas exprimé
mon opinion personnelle, j'ai dit
comment la lecture était faite.
-Oui, voilà.
-On va le laisser exprimer
son opinion personnelle après.
-C'est parce que,
je l'ai déjà dit
au début de cette émission,
on fait une confusion
monumentale entre la Palestine,
les droits du peuple palestinien
et l'Etat terroriste créé
par le Hamas,
même si une grande partie
de l'opinion publique
palestinienne
en désespoir de cause
soutient l'action du Hamas,
c'est pas la même chose.
Je pense qu'il faut une fois pour
toutes trancher entre le Hamas...
-J'ai vécu 5 ans à Jérusalem
et j'y ai été correspondant,
je ne fais pas la confusion.
Soyez-en sûre.
-Bien sûr.
-On peut avoir des opinions
divergentes. Claude Moniquet.
-Oui, je dois dire
que ce qui m'a étonné, Jérôme Guedj
a raison de la souligner,
dans l'extrême gauche,
pas dans la gauche en général,
puisque des gens de gauche
soutiennent Israël,
même si on peut critiquer
certaines méthodes
utilisées par Israël,
c'est un débat parallèle.
Ce qui m'a surpris
ou pas vraiment d'ailleurs
dans les positions
de l'extrême gauche,
c'est cette confusion entre défendre
les civils palestiniens,
la population palestinienne,
défendre théoriquement
l'autonomie et la liberté
de la Palestine
et défendre le Hamas.
Ce sont des choses non seulement
différentes, mais contradictoires.
Le Hamas est sans doute le pire
ennemi de la cause palestinienne.
Il faut être très clair là-dessus.
Et en le soutenant...
Et quand on voit ces jeunes
défiler en criant
"de la rivière à la mer",
ce serait presque drôle
si c'était pas triste.
La mer, ils la situent à peu près,
quoique certains pensent
que c'est la mer Rouge,
mais le fleuve,
quand on leur dit quel fleuve,
là, on est un peu perdu.
C'est triste. Ca montre
qu'on a mal expliqué les choses.
Ca montre qu'il y a eu
énormément de propagande
qui visait non pas, de nouveau,
à défendre la Palestine,
ce qui est une cause tout à fait
juste. Moi, depuis toujours,
et quand je vivais en Israël,
c'était déjà ma position,
je suis pour une paix à deux Etats,
c'est la seule qui soit raisonnable.
Il y a aucune garantie
qu'elle apportera la paix.
La seule garantie, c'est que,
si on ne va pas vers cette paix,
on continuera à avoir
la guerre pour 1000 ans.
C'est ça qu'il faut dire.
Il faut dire
que le Hamas est l'ennemi
de la cause palestinienne
et dénoncer le Hamas, qui est une
organisation criminelle, terroriste
et quasiment génocidaire.
-Edouard Guyot.
-Il y a un autre point, on confond
un tout petit peu le Hamas
et on l'assimile à la bande de Gaza.
Le Hamas existerait
sans la bande de Gaza.
Le Hamas a fait son nid
dans un territoire,
mais le Hamas, en réalité,
on voit bien
qu'il n'en a rien à faire
de perdre ou pas Gaza.
Lui, il se reconstituera ailleurs,
il migrera
et ça restera une organisation,
ce sont
les Frères musulmans qui y font
penser, liée aux Frères musulmans,
dont le but est
la destruction d'Israël d'une part
et le but
des Frères musulmans
est d'avoir un islam politique
régnant sur le maximum
de territoires de la planète
d'autre part. Donc il faut bien
séparer, en plus à mon avis,
la question de la bande de Gaza,
qui amène
les problèmes de destruction,
les victimes collatérales et tout
ce qui est absolument épouvantable
en opérations militaires
en zone très urbanisée,
de l'attaque et la volonté affichée
et qui me paraît normale d'ailleurs,
de vouloir détruire
le Hamas en tant que tel. Ce sont
deux aspects différents.
On a tendance à dire,
si Israël prend tout Gaza
ou réoccupe tout Gaza
comme il y a quelques années,
il y a plus de Hamas. Non,
c'est pas vrai. Il y aura toujours
un Hamas, il ira ailleurs.
Et les autres Etats arabes
n'ont aucune envie de le voir
arriver chez eux.
A Gaza, au moins, il est cantonné.
-La vocation du monde arabe serait
de secréter
un extrémisme islamiste ?
-Non, pas du tout.
-Bah alors ?
-Non, mais ce qui se passe
pour l'instant,
les Etats arabes et musulmans,
arabes musulmans, en général,
soutiennent assez peu et on le sait
bien la cause palestinienne,
ça, on le voit depuis 30, 40 ans,
et ne la ressortent
que quand ça leur apporte
un gain diplomatique ou un gain
de politique étrangère
pour l'opinion internationale.
Finalement,
ça arrange un peu tout le monde.
Il y a un prurit qui s'est créé,
qu'il reste à Gaza.
-Claude Moniquet.
-Je reconnais que c'est
horrible ce que je dis.
-Je suis d'accord
avec l'amiral Guyot.
Il y a un but de guerre israélien
qui est assez irréaliste,
c'est de détruire le Hamas,
ce qui ne veut pas dire grand-chose.
L'offensive israélienne peut
affaiblir le Hamas.
Une série d'autres mesures
légalement discutables
comme les assassinats ciblés
qui se poursuivent
dans des pays où sont réfugiés
des dirigeants du Hamas
peuvent également affaiblir
l'organisation.
Mais en tant qu'idée,
elle va continuer à exister
et elle s'incarnera
d'une manière ou d'une autre
soit dans le Hamas
soit dans un autre mouvement.
Ca n'est pas que le monde arabe
a vocation à sécréter l'extrémisme,
il y a des courants
extrêmement modérés,
mais il y a dans le monde arabe,
en tout cas certainement
depuis 20 à 30 ans,
une tendance salafiste,
Frères musulmans, extrémiste,
qui est importante, qui est
minoritaire, mais importante,
et qui continuera à s'exprimer.
Donc le Hamas ne sera pas
éradiqué, il sera affaibli
et au moment où il le sera,
il faut en profiter
pour faire avancer les négociations,
les possibilités de cette paix
ou de cette neutralisation
du conflit
avec une négociation aux deux Etats,
avant que le Hamas ou son successeur
puisse reprendre la main.
-Je voudrais aborder la question
que vous avez soulignée
dès le départ, Jérôme Guedj,
sur la question
de pourquoi ces guerres
sont des guerres
de civilisations.
On doit à Samuel Huntington
une prévision contestée
sur le conflit des civilisations.
Certains ont considéré que c'était
exact, d'autres ont considéré
que c'était erroné.
Mais au regard des conflits actuels,
on en a parlé
depuis un moment,
quoi penser de la prévision reprise
par de nombreux observateurs
que les conflits les plus étendus
que nous observons
appartiennent à des entités
culturelles différentes ?
Etes-vous au moins
d'accord avec ça ?
-Non, je vous redis que je récuse
l'idée du choc des civilisations.
-Non, on ne parle pas du choc
des civilisations.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
ces conflits opposent
des entités culturelles différentes
au regard de la polarisation
du monde ?
-Non.
Le meilleur contre-exemple,
déjà évoqué, je considère pas
que l'Ukraine et la Russie
participent d'identités culturelles
différentes. Voilà. C'est d'ailleurs
ça qui est terrible. Nous avons
un conflit sur le sol européen
entre Européens
avec des spécificités, des histoires
particulières...
-Mais l'Ukraine vous est
plus proche
que la Russie culturellement,
oui ou non ?
-Sincèrement, jusque-là...
Aujourd'hui, l'Ukraine m'est proche
quand elle dit, mon avenir face à
la menace que représente la Russie,
mon avenir,
c'est de demander l'adhésion
à l'Union européenne.
Ca verra le jour
dans 15, 20, 30 ans. Moi,
je suis un Européen qui croit
en effet que les espaces
de coopération sont
ceux qui permettent
précisément de sortir.
Pendant des années, on a considéré
qu'il y avait une identité boche
et une identité française
incompatibles
et on a réussi à les mettre
dans un creuset commun.
-On vous a entendu.
-Donc, oui,
je récuse les chocs de
civilisations, parce que derrière,
je vois bien la petite musique,
je le redis,
celle du camp du bien et du mal.
-Personne n'a parlé
de ça.
-Qui décide ?
-Laissez-moi, Jérôme Guedj,
que chacun donne
son avis...
-Pour mettre de l'eau
à votre moulin, un des endroits
où il y a le plus grand,
l'un des plus grands risques
de guerre mondiale, c'est Taïwan.
Entre Taïwan et la Chine, doit-on
parler de conflit de civilisations ?
-Philippe Gélie, sincèrement,
à titre personnel,
vous êtes plus proche
de Taïwan culturellement
ou de la Chine ?
C'est une vraie question.
-C'est une question
à laquelle il n'y a pas de réponse.
-Mais si !
-Mais non.
Pour moi, il n'y a pas,
ça n'est pas un conflit de
civilisations, c'est un conflit...
-Personne ne parle de conflit.
-Entre la démocratie et le
communisme. Taïwan étant soutenue
par les démocraties européennes
et américaines
et le régime communiste chinois
s'alliant avec un régime
autoritaire en Russie.
-Y a-t-il
des affiliations culturelles ?
-Non, pour moi, c'est pas
un conflit de civilisations.
-Galia Ackerman, sur ce point.
Sur ce point ?
-Depuis quelques années, la Russie a
une idée, qui a été empruntée
à l'extrême droite, bon, maintenant,
tout le régime est extrême droite,
mais ça date encore
de quelques années
quand le philosophe
Alexandre Douguine
que tout le monde maintenant connaît
a proclamé qu'en fait,
il y a plusieurs grandes
civilisations dans le monde,
que la Russie est
un Etat civilisation et que
la civilisation occidentale
ne doit pas être
prépondérante,
elle doit être au même titre
que les autres civilisations
et que donc
eux, c'est une civilisation
occidentale perverse,
délétère, impérialiste, etc.,
mais bon, on va les laisser
dans leur fange.
Mais il faut que tout soit
à l'égalité, ce qui veut dire aussi
que chaque cordonnier est
maître chez soi. Si la civilisation
chinoise traditionnellement
est autoritaire,
c'est comme ça. Si la civilisation
russe ou ce qu'ils appellent
la civilisation russe est contre
LGBT, eh bien, ainsi soit-il.
Et donc, ce qui se passe en Ukraine,
c'est pas même... Oui,
on peut dire que c'est un conflit
entre civilisations,
la pseudo-civilisation russe
et la civilisation occidentale
par le corps de l'Ukraine interposé.
C'est leur interprétation.
Qu'ils combattent l'Occident
en la personne de l'Ukraine.
-On a très peu de temps.
Je voudrais avoir deux autres
avis et je crois qu'on vous a
entendue. Vous voulez conclure ?
-Oui,
ce que je veux dire,
c'est que le propos russe
est encore plus pernicieux.
Il considère
que l'Ukraine n'est ni civilisation,
ni Etat, ni culture propre,
que c'est une sorte de variation
avec la Russie, qu'il faut la
détacher de l'Occident, conquérir...
-En somme, effacer l'Ukraine,
ils l'ont déjà dit.
Edouard Guyot, pas de guerre froide,
mais on constate une polarisation
du monde.
-On constate une polarisation
avec une dimension qu'à mon avis,
nous n'avons pas abordée,
qui est la dimension religieuse.
Moscou se voit
comme la nouvelle Rome.
Et je vais paraphraser Poutine,
tout ce qui est orthodoxe est russe.
Donc la moitié
des Balkans est russe, par exemple.
La religion,
c'est le marxisme,
le léninisme chinois,
leur sert de religion.
On a parlé de l'Iran tout à l'heure,
eh bien, c'est le chiisme.
Et puis les Frères musulmans,
je parle pas des pays,
mais les Frères musulmans,
c'est une forme de sunnisme.
Ceci sous-tend
à chaque fois la civilisation.
Vous avez
une religion
ou l'équivalent d'une religion
plus une histoire commune,
plus des aspects culturels communs.
-Merci. Claude Moniquet,
il nous reste moins
d'une minute, sur ce point
et sur cette polarisation du monde ?
-Je crois
que la polarisation n'est pas
entre civilisation et culture
mais entre modèles politiques.
Vous avez une partie du monde
qui croit, qui est assez restreinte,
à la démocratie
et au droit international et
vous avez ceux qui n'y croient pas.
Le problème est là. Le deuxième
problème, c'est que nous,
l'Occident global,
comme vous disiez,
on n'a pas été toujours
à la hauteur de nos idéaux,
à la hauteur
de ce que nous devrions être
et ça a entraîné
la désaffection d'une partie,
de gens qui ne sont pas les acteurs
principaux du Sud global,
mais qui sont les suiveurs,
qui vont se retrouver
derrière la Russie,
la Chine ou d'autres.
Ils pensent qu'ils sont plus à même
de les défendre contre nous
qui ne sommes pas à la hauteur
et qui pratiquons trop souvent
le deux poids deux mesures.
-Merci.
Il me reste peu de temps, sinon
pour vous présenter quelques livres
qui traitent du sujet
que nous avons évoqué.
Bruno Tertrais :
Paru aux éditions de l'Observatoire.
Je voudrais rappeler
votre livre,
Galia Ackerman. Vous avez publié
avec Stéphane Courtois
"Le livre noir
de Vladimir Poutine".
Claude Moniquet,
je voudrais rappeler
que vous avez publié
"Djihad et islamisme en Belgique",
aux éditions Jourdan Le Clercq.
En un mot, mais vraiment
en 20 secondes,
comment se porte
le djihadisme d'ambiance
à Molenbeek
et dans toute la Belgique ?
-Il se porte aussi bien
qu'à Roubaix-Tourcoing
ou que dans la banlieue de Toulouse
ou que dans celle de Londres. Il y a
un mouvement salafiste qui existe,
qui continue à croître, moins
fortement qu'il y a 5 ou 6 ans,
mais qui est toujours là et dont
une partie prône le djihad armé.
-Excusez-moi, Claude. Merci.
Je vais terminer avec Jérôme Guedj.
Vous avez été l'objet
d'une cabale antisémite.
Alors, encore sur ce sujet,
cette cabale intervient au moment
où les actes antisémites sont très
nombreux, on va pas faire
l'histoire de l'antisémitisme,
il n'en est pas question,
mais à votre avis, quelle est
la marque de fabrique politique
de l'antisémitisme
qui vous a visé ?
-Il est universel. Ce que j'ai reçu,
quand on me traite de "youpin",
je peux pas savoir si ça vient
de l'antisémitisme profond
de l'histoire de l'extrême droite
en France, je peux pas savoir
si ça vient
du nouvel antisémitisme
de l'islamisme radical.
Par contre, il y a une chose,
d'ailleurs on le voit
dans les conflits internationaux.
A la fin, il reste des antisémites,
quels que soient les conflits.
-Vous y associez
l'islamo-gauchisme ?
-Je viens de vous le dire.
C'est quelque chose
qui est partagé par tous ceux
qui remettent
en question les piliers
de la République et parfois,
ça se croise et ça se parle
aux uns et aux autres.
-Merci,
Madame, merci,
Messieurs,
d'avoir participé,
merci à l'équipe de LCP
qui a réalisé cette émission.
Et avant de nous quitter, je vous
laisse avec cette pensée :
"Les puissances occidentales
n'ont pas de meilleur moyen
"de servir la paix du monde
que de rester droites et fermes."
Edouard Guyot, c'est qui, ça ?
-It rings a bell,
comme on dit en français.
-C'est le général de Gaulle.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA